قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلينت ان تل ابيب
شكرت الاداره الامريكيه على ما سماه دعمها
غير المشروط للعمليه العسكريه التي نفذها
جيش الاحتلال في جنين مؤخرا جاء ذلك في
اتصال هاتفي مع وزير الدفاع الامريكي
وقال
اعرب خلاله عن قلقه من تصعيد العنف في
الضفه الغربيه بما في ذلك هجمات
المستوطنين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي حقيقه ما سماه
الوزير الاسرائيلي الدعم غير المشروط الذي
قدمته اداره بايدن لعمليه قوات الاحتلال
العسكريه الاخيره في جنين وما طبيعه هذا
الدعم والى اي حد يمكن ان تشكل عمليه جنين
مدخلا لمقاربه مختلفه تتخذها اداره بايدن
ازاء سياسه حكومه اليمين المتطرف في
اسرائيل والتحفظات التي ابدتها تجاهها
خلال المرحله المقبله وما هي الانعكاسات
المحتمله لهذا التوجه على دور واشنطن كراع
لعمليه السلام وما هي حساباتها في التعامل
مع الاوضاع الراهنه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
على خلاف تحفظات طالما اكدت اداره الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن انها تطبع علاقتها
بحكومه اليمين المتطرف في اسرائيل بقياده
بنيامين نتنياهو ورغم الانتقادات
الامريكيه للسياسه الاستيانيه لتلك
الحكومه
ولمساعيها لادخال تعديلات القضائيه جوهريه
كشف وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي افجالنت عن
انه استعرض مع نظيره الامريكي
ما سماها اهميه العمليه العسكريه في جنين
لمنع لجمات الارهابيه على المواطنين وقوات
الامن في اسرائيل وفق قوله جلنت اضاف انه
اعرب لاوسن عن شكر اسرائيل للاداره
الامريكيه بسبب ما سماه دعمها غير المشروط
للعمليه العسكريه التي نفذها جيش الاحتلال
في مدينه جنين واسفرت عن استشهاد واصابه
عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين من جانبه قال
المتحدث باسم البنتاغون ان الوزيره اوسن
اعرب لنظيره الاسرائيلي عن قلق واشنطن
العميق من تصاعد العنف في الضفه الغربيه
بما في ذلك هجمات المستوطنين المتطرفين
على المدنيين الفلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من واشنطن ديفيد
بولغر عضو مكتب جو بايدن عندما كان
سيناتورا والمستشار السابق لشؤون الامن
القوميه الامريكي ومن رام الله الدكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مرحبا بكما سيد ديفيد
ابدا معك هل صحيح ان واشنطن تدعم بشكل غير
محدود العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في
جنين كما قال يؤف قلند حيث قدم شكره
لواشنطن على هذا الدعم غير المشروط لها
ان هناك
نوع من التلاعب بالكلمات في هذا المجال
فقد تعلق الامر بتعريف الدعم
انا الولايات المتحده كانت وما ستستمر في
الدعم دوله اسرائيل بعدد ضد طرق دعم مالي
والدعم اقتصادي ودعم اجتماعي وما الى ذلك
ولكن بشكل محدد اداره بايدن عليها ان تكون
حذره جدا اذاعه ما يحصل في جنين وما يحصل
في عمليه التصعيد في الظفر الغربيه على يد
اداره نتنياهو وبالتالي ثمه جزئين في هذا
اولا يجب
نفصل الدعم المالي المستمر للتقدمه
الولايات المتحده عن طريق الكونجرس وعن
طريق
قانون التخصيصات تقدمه لاسرائيل منذ سنوات
واي جانب اخر وجزء الاخر هو ما الذي يحصل
بشكل محدد في ما بعد مرحله ماساه جنين حيث
قتل مدنيون وان هذا امر لا يمكن الولايات
المتحده ان توافق عليه اطلاقا ولكن
هل بدا اثناء عمليه جنين موقف امريكي
مغاير لمقاله اثناء شن اسرائيل لهذه
العمليه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله في
جنين حيث ارتكبت اسرائيل ما ارتكبته من
عمليات قتل وترويع وتهجير للسكان هناك هل
بدا موقف في واشنطن غير الذي تحدث عنه
اعتقد ذلك
اعتقد ان السيد
تصرف بشكل كبير في في كلامه او في طريقه
التعبير وتعريفه للدعم نعم اعتقد بالتاكيد
هناك اختلاف في هذا الصدد اداره بايدن هذا
الاسبوع انا رايت ارى انها لم تكون شديده
او عدوانيه كما ينبغي فيما يتعلق بالتواصل
وعدم الموافق على مثل هذا النوع من السلوك
والماساه التي حصلت ان
ان هذا يعتبر كانه صندوق اسرار حيث هناك
دائما احتمال التصعيد بشكل كبير واعتقد ان
اداره عليها ان تقوم بالتواصل اقوى على كل
المستويات للتاكد من ان الامور لا تخرج عن
السيطره ولله من حيث الاحتمالات اننا نحن
ازاءه ازاء ربما شيء اكثر ماساويه مصطفى
هل تتفق مع السيد ديفيد بان واشنطن كانت
يعني كان لديها موقف مختلف عما تحدث عنه
يعني اراد ان يظهره للعلن من حيث الدعم
غير المشروط لو واشنطن اثناء العمليه
العسكريه في جنين يعني كنت تتابع تحدثت
بان الموقف الامريكي والغربي هو كان شبه
متواطئ
هلا شيئا مختلفا
لو كان لديهم شيء مختلف عليهم ان يعلنوه
ولكن هم لم يعلقوا على مقاله جالنت بل
بالعكس الموقف المعلن الامريكي الرسمي
والبريطاني ايضا كان اعتبار ما تقوم به
اسرائيل من جريمه حرب في جنين عمليه دفاع
عن النفس استخدام جيش الاحتلال بكل جبروته
وطائراته ومدرعاته ودباباته ضد مدنيين تحت
احتلاله هذا ليس سوى جريمه حرب تهجير 4000
انسان بالقوه المسلحه من منازلهم ليس سوى
جريمه حرب قتل اربع اطفال بالاضافه الى
الشهداء الاخرين ليس سوى جريمه حرب في
الواقع ان السكوت على الجريمه الاسرائيليه
بالاضافه الى القول انها عمليه دفاع عن
النفس
والسكوت على ما يقوله جلانت الان بانه
تلقى دعما غير مشروط من واشنطن هو في
الواقع تواطؤ مع هذه الجريمه ومشاركه فيها
وهذا امر مرفوض جمله وتفصيلا
اقول اخت سلمى ان الموضوع هنا ليس فقط
التواطئ مع الجريمه التي ارتكبت في جنين
هناك تواطئ مع استمرار الاحتلال تواطئ مع
نظام الابرتايد العنصري وهذا ليس كلامنا
فقط هذا كلام
[موسيقى]
هناك نظام ابارتايد تسكت عليه واشنطن
وهناك تواطئ مع حقيقه انه حكومه استعماريه
استيطانيه فيها فاشيين مثل
تقوم بتحطيم اي امكانيه لوجود دوله
فلسطينيه ويعلن نتنياهو صراحه انه ليس فقط
سيمنع قيام دوله فلسطينيه بل سيجتس الفكره
من اساسها ماذا فعلت الولايات المتحده هل
وقفت ضده هل اتخذت اجراءات عقابيه هل
هددته باجراءات عقابيه لا لم تفعل شيئا
وبالتالي طبعا النتيجه ان هناك تواطئ مع
هذا الذي يجري وهذا يدمر اي ادعاء بان
الولايات المتحده دور في العمليه السياسيه
في المستقبل
ما رايك بمثل هذا
الكلام او الرؤيه الفلسطينيه السكوت عن
الجرائم المقترفه والمرتكبه هو بالنهايه
يعتبر يعني موافقه عدم الادانه هي موافقه
بالتالي يحق لينك ان يتحدث عن دعم مع
طبيعه هذا الدعم الذي تلقته حكومه نتنياهو
في هذه العمليه هل برايك كان دعم سياسي
دعم عسكري لوجستي ما نوعه
لابد ان هناك
التواصل واتصالات اكثر من قبل البيت
الابيض
وايضا توضيح من وزاره الخارجيه لان هذا
الامر يحصل في وقت ان الولايات المتحده في
اسبوع اجازه او عضل
وكانك تردد في التواصل في وقت للكل الناس
فيه مسافرون وبالتالي كما قلت سابقا هذا
الامر لابد ان هناك ادانه ايداع اي كلما
يكون هناك مدنيون يتعرضون للقتل بهذه
الطريقه الماساويه
فهذا هذا هذا هذا امر لا يمكن قبوله
والولايات المتحده لديها موقف مؤكد بان
اسرائيل تستطيع ان تدافع عن نفسها اذا ما
اذا ما اذا كان هو فقط للتاكد بانه ليس
اقناع منظمه ارهابيه داخل منطقه جنين
وبالتالي
هذا امر
لا يؤثر على الدعم الذي تقدمه المتحده
للتاكد من اسرائيل تستطيع الدفاع عن نفسها
ولكن عندما يحصل تصعيد وعندما نصل الى بعض
الدعم الجوي
واستخدام اسلحه اخرى هذا امر لا يجب ان
نقبله واعتقد الولايات المتحده واداره
بايدن بشكل خاص تجد نفسها في موقف
انه علينا ان نخفف الامور ونتاكد بان
الاعمال العوف هذه لن تزداد بمزيد من
الجرحى والقتله والتاكد من انه حصول اي
هجمات اخرى سيد دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي يعني
الا يمكن اخذ يعني ايضا تصريحات الامريكيه
هي يعني قلقه من مستويات العنفيه تدين
الاستيطان وهي ايضا يعني ادانت العمليات
للمستوطنين المتطرفين ودعواتهم للاباده
وحرق الذي جرى في ترمس عيا وفي ايضا
حواره ضمن السياق الذي يعني المنوط بها
كدوله راعيه لعمليات السلام
يا اختي الادانات والاستنكارات لا تعني
شيء لنتنياهو
اكثر دوله في العالم تستطيع ان تضغط على
اسرائيل هي الولايات المتحده
ساجيبك على السؤال الذي وجهتيه لضيفك
الامريكي ماذا تقدم الولايات المتحده
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل اسرائيل ام الولايات
المتحده تقدم لاسرائيل كل الاسلحه من
طائرات الاف 35 الى الاف 16 الى الاباتشي
الى المدرعات الى كل شيء الولايات المتحده
تعطي اسرائيل ثلاث مليارات دولار سنويا
مساعدات عسكريه واعطاها بايضا في هذا
العام مليار اضافي لتطوير انظمتها
الدفاعيه الجويه الولايات المتحده تسمح
بجمع تبرعات لاسرائيل لا تقل عن 12 مليار
دولار سنويا الولايات المتحده هي التي
تمنع اتخاذ اي قرار في مجلس الامن ضد
الجرائم الاسرائيليه وتحمي اسرائيل ليس
فقط في مجلس الامن بل في كل المحافل
الدوليه ووصل الامر الى حد انسحاب
الولايات المتحده من اليونسكو دعما
لاسرائيل الذي يجري دعم مطلق وكامل لو
الولايات المتحده لو ارادت تستطيع ان تجبر
اسرائيل في عشر دقائق على الاقل على وقف
الاستيطان الذي تدينه وتقول انه يدمر
امكانيه قيام دوله فلسطينيه مستقله لماذا
لا تفعل ذلك الكلام والادانات
والاستنكارات لا تعني شيئا وبالتالي
الاسرائيليون فعلا فهموا الرساله بشكل
واضح ان اسرائيل تتلقى دعما غير مشروط
وكامل من الولايات المتحده وهذا ما يشجعها
على القيام بكل هذه الجرائم اليوم جيش
الاحتلال قام باغتيال شاب في انصفه لم يكن
يفعل شيئا اعدام ميداني بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه لم نسمع ايضا موقفا من ذلك الامر
كل الشعب الفلسطيني
الولايات المتحده في مقاربتها للقضيه
الفلسطينيه والعلاقه مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه هي موضع
تساؤل ايضا الى اي درجه مثل هذا الموقف
غير الجدي كراعيه لعمليه السلام يعني
يضعها ضمن حسابات بانها تشجع هذه الحكومه
حكومه نتنياهو على الذهاب للمزيد من هذه
العمليات التي تنتهك فيها
قوانين تخص جرائم الحرب وما الى ذلك
ان الرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو
بالتصعيد الى حد بعيد جدا وهذا امر
الولايات المتحده بشكل خاص اداره بايدن
برئاسه بايدن وحتى عندما كان نائبا للرئيس
وقبل ذلك عندما كان
فهو مطلع جدا على ما يقوم به نتنياهو
وموقفه اليمين المتطرف
ليس هناك علاقه وثيقه بين
ميدار نتنياهو واداره بايدن وهذا امر واضح
جدا ولكن الولايات المتحده رغم ذلك ملتزمه
حل الدولتين
ويعملون على القنوات الدبلوماسيه في هذا
الصدد وما حصل في الايام العشر الماضيه
طبعا يضر بشكل كبير
بمصداقيه المفاوضات الجاريه ولكن
ايضا يجعل الامر اكثر صعوبه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده لتواصل دعمها وعود القول
ايضا ليس هناك دعم غير مشروط بالتاكيد
هناك نوع من التطرف لن نسمح به مثل ما
يحصل حاليا في جنين وبالتالي
اعتقد لان هناك توضيح او اكبر لانه من
وزاره الخارجيه والمجلس الامن القومي
باننا سندفع ونشجع جهودنا في الايام
القادمه للتاكد من الولايات المتحده لا
يمكن ان توافق على مثل هذا السلوك الذي
حصل في جنين دكتور مصطفى كيف ستكون
انعكاسات هذا الموقف الامريكي
الداعم لحكومه نتنياهو في الحفاظ على
امنها كما تقول الاداره الامريكيه
على اجواء الغضب الموجوده في الضفه
الغربيه في الشارع الفلسطيني بشكل عام
كاس الاول ان هناك فقدان كامل للثقه ليس
فقط بالولايات المتحده بل بالمجتمع الدولي
ككل ولم يعد الفلسطينيون يراهنون على تدخل
من المجتمع الدولي يراهنون على الدعم
الشعبي على حركات التضامن على حركات
المقاطعه وفرض العقوبات على اسرائيل على
شعوب والاحزاب المتضامنه مع الشعب
الفلسطيني ولكن ليس على هذه الحكومات التي
تواصل الكيل بمكيالين ولذلك التاثير الاول
المباشر لهذه السياسه الامريكيه هو براي
تعميق شعور الفلسطينيين بضروره الاعتماد
على النفس
وتعميق شعورهم بانه لا حل سوى المقاومه
والكفاح وان اسرائيل لن ترضع الا بالنضال
والكفاح والمقاومه ويعزز ذلك في الواقع ان
المقارنه بين موقف الولايات المتحده في
اوكرانيا والغرب عموما وبينما يجري في
فلسطين
لماذا في اوكرانيا يقول هناك احتلال ايضا
لماذا اعطوهم الاسلحه واعطوهم المدرعات
والطائرات ومليارات الدولارات ليحاربوا
روسيا وفرضوا 11 الف عقوبه على روسيا في
غضون شهرين ولا عقوبه واحده على اسرائيل
بل بالعكس الدعم والاسلحه تاتي لاسرائيل
الامر الثاني كيف توصف المقاومه المشروعه
الفلسطينيه حسب القانون الدولي لشعب يدافع
عن نفسه ضد الاحتلال بانها ارهاب وهنا
الارهاب تصنف ارهاب مش بس حماس والجهاد
الاسلامي حتى منظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه ما
زالت مصنفه كانها ارهاب في الكونجرس
الامريكي واداره بايدن عجزت عن فعل اشياء
بسيطه حتى فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في
القدس الذي وعدت به لم تفعله حتى فتح مكتب
منظمه التحرير في واشنطن لم تستطع ان
تفعله الشيء الوحيد الذي تفعله انها تواصل
سياسه ترامب بالضغط على البلدان العربيه
وخاصه المملكه العربيه السعوديه للتطبيع
مع اسرائيل رغم ان ترفض ذلك اذا الذي يجري
هو نفس السياسه التي كانت متبعه في زمن
ترامب نحن لا نرى جديه والولايات المتحده
في الواقع تفقد مصداقيتها وبالتاكيد فقدت
دورها كوسيط لما سمي بعمليه مثل وجهه
النظر التي تعبر عن شارع كبير في يعني راي
كبير في الشارع الفلسطيني والسؤال هنا هل
يشكل ما حدث تطورا يعني حتى يعني تجاوز او
عدم الادانه من قبل اداره
بايدن للعمليه العسكريه سيشكل مدخلا
لتغيير في طبيعه العلاقه ما بين اداره
بايدن وحكومه نتنياهو ضمن المحددات التي
كانت اساسا هي تحكم هذه العلاقه رؤيه
اداره بايدن لحكومه بانها تحوي متطرفين لا
تريد التعامل معهم بنت كثير
ايضا ادانتها للاستيطان وادانتها ايضا
للتعديلات القضائيه التي يحاول
نتنياهو ان يقوم بها
اداره
كانت تعلم عندما وصلت الى السلطه في يناير
بان
ان اداره نتنياهو ليس صديقه
لاداره الامريكيه ولكنهم
كانوا في موقفين لابد التعامل معه وهذا ما
يقومون به
فهم يعملون في كل قنوات الدبلوماسيه ليس
فقط في اسرائيل ايضا مع الفلسطينيين
والسلطه الفلسطينيه ومع اطراف الاقليميه
اخرى
للتوصل من حيث المبدا الى مدعونا ان نركز
على السلام ويمكن ان يتحقق وفي الوقت ذاته
اداره بايدن تعلم جيدا
ان
التوجه اليمين المتطرف نتنياهو مجموعته
وهنا يكمن
ما نقوله اننا نتعامل بشكل يومي فقط
اين موقفنا اليوم للتواصل نوع من الحل لكي
نستطيع ان ننقذ او نوقف هذه الهجمات وايضا
افعال قد يتسم بها الفلسطينيين او
المنظمات
الموجوده ضمن الضفه الغربيه مثل حماس
والجهاد الاسلامي وغيرها مجموعات
الارهابيه الذين يحصلون على التمويل لهم
من ايران ودول اخرى هؤلاء لابد من
سماح حسابات واشنطن في التعامل مع الاوضاع
الراهنه الان في الاراضي الفلسطينيه التي
واضح بانها تغلي
وهناك حاله غضب كبير
ة بايدن فعلا تعي حصول ذلك وتريد ان تتاكد
بانها تتعامل وتصل مع الشركاء الاقليميين
بل ايضا معلومه من المتحده
في اليوم في المتحده هناك تصريحات تصدر
حول السلوك الاسرائيلي وهذه احدى القنوات
التي من حيث الاساس ان نسمي الامور
بالمسمياتها وبالتالي في اداره بايدن على
رايه لديه امامها ايام واسابيع صعبه جدا
بل واشهر صعبه جدا عليهم اثناءها ان
ان يتاكدوا من الامور لا تخرج عن السيطره
هل نتوقع سيد ديفيد في عجاله ان نرى
بنيامين نتنياهو في البيت الابيض قريبا
لا اتوقع ان رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو سيزور
واشنطن اعتقد
ان الرئيس بايدن
يحترم
كمنصب من يقود وراسه اسرائيل
واذا كان ضروريا يجتمعاه
فلو كان كان الاجتماع مثمرا لكن لحد الان
لا يمكن اجتماعاتنااهو مثمره في السابق
اذا تذكرون اثناء ادارته اوباما تحدث مع
الكانغرس لكن لم يلتقي بالرئيس اوباما
وبالتالي اعتقد ان هناك تاريخ وراء هذا
الامر فلو ان الجمهوريين
والبيت اذا ارادوا دعوته بامكانه ذلك
انه هل ترى بان يعني هناك حسابات مختلفه
ستكون لدى اداره بايدن بسبب حاله الغليان
الموجوده في الضفه الغربيه وخوفا من
التصعيد
انا امل ان يكون هناك مراجعه للموقف
الامريكي ولكن لا اعتقد ان ذلك سيحدث لان
الاداره الامريكيه تخاف من اللوبي
الاسرائيلي واذا كان سيحدث تغيير فهو
التغيير الذي سيحدث نتيجه
التحول الكبير في قاعده الحزب الديمقراطي
في الولايات المتحده بفضل جهودنا كشعب
فلسطيني وبفضل جهود المناصرين
49% من اعضاء الحزب الديمقراطي الان
مؤيدون للشعب الفلسطيني مقابل 36% مؤيدون
لاسرائيل هذا هو العمل الذي يجب ان يستمر
يجب ان نضغط من القاعده الشعبيه ويجب ايضا
ان نوضح للعالم ان من النفاق والخداع
والتخدير محاوله تخدير الناس عندما
يواصلوا الحديث عن حل الدولتين وهم يرون
اسرائيل تذبح حل الدولتين بالمعنى الحرفي
للكلمه شكرا جزيلا لك من رام الله دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام للمبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه واشكر ايضا جزيلا من
واشنطن ضيفي دي
عضو مكتب عندما كان سيناتورا والمستشار
السابق لشؤون الامن القوميه الامريكي شكرا
جزيلا لكما الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]